der co-pilot peter b hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer endlich mal wieder so pvp
server action bla bla es ist kein pvp
sondern wir machen ein wenig wie spieler
die nicht denken das camp auf dem all
blacks server ich habe schon sehr lange
nichts mehr auf den main plextor bell
gemacht ich weiß auch gar nicht genau
wie das der spielmodus hier funktioniert
ich nehme einfach besser jetzt einfach
mal ich weiß nicht genau was die
fähigkeiten aber nicht wahrscheinlich
einfach laufen
man muss in diesem spielmodus halt
einfach nur laufen muss von einem dach
hinweg laufen in der alle blöcke kaputt
schlägt und die map habe ich noch nie
gespielt und ich weiß nicht den weg
ließen der weg muss dem langlaufen muss
sich langlaufen jungs ich glaube der
life ball hinterher
ich habe angst oder weil oder acht wie
spielen gerade gar nicht denken es geht
wir spielen ja ak hat ach so gut und
jetzt ich habe keine ahnung dieser
spielmodus funktioniert wahrscheinlich
hätten jetzt wiederum aber ich wollte
eigentlich trainingscamp spielen weil
das relativ simpel ist für sowas und man
bedenkt dass kate wirklich einfach nur
laufen muss oder unten boxen sich welche
das müssen wir dann machen wir müssen
die teile töten oder also würde ich
jetzt mal grob sagen dass ich oder
moment ist der tod
ja gut egal spiel das einfach mal ein
bisschen mit ich wollt euch ein bisschen
mein jahr zusammenfassen weil ich habe
gesehen dass sehr viele leute review b
star usher wenn man selbst steht dass
man selbst zwar okay das kann sei
natürlich das klingt logisch
ich wollte ich mein ja so ein bisschen
zusammenfassen jahr 2013
weil keine ahnung das macht zurzeit
irgendwie jeder so dass jahr
zusammenfassen 2013 aber ich würde sagen
dass man das eigentlich erst machen
sollte wenn wirklich das ja auch vorbei
ist und nicht irgendwie schon
weiß nicht 10 millionen was ist denn
jetzt ist vorbei ich habe keine macht
einfach irgendwas hier in minecraft
kommt einfach nicht in hört euch das nur
an man jahr 2013 war geprägt durch
schule youtube freunde halt alles
mögliche so an hobbys sport etc nur auf
youtube jetzt bezogen möchte ich das mal
kurz zusammenfassen ganz kurz weg nicht
nur einmal eigentlich wollten ein paar
leute an gesagt dass ich mal wieder hier
auf meinem platz spielen soll und hab
ich mir gedacht dass ich das doch dann
einfach mal machen das spiel denn jetzt
jetzt spielen wir hier eine krippe okay
ja aber zu anfang des jahres war es halt
so ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau welche
ganzen projektes hatte ich hatte nur
halt the beast mit mit mit simon woraus
dann letztendlich auch das mega also fit
babys deutlich mehr so eine idee david
ticket bei ein paar amerikanischen
leuten gesehen haben haben wir uns
gedacht dass wir das ganze auch viele
beats beziehen mit mehr technik und so
dass dann also bei uns so machen in der
deutschen rings und bisschen das fahren
kann
killer er steht einfach rum auch gut den
hätte ich auch einfach einfach so töten
können aber nein so bin ich nicht so
christa da er hat den pfeil warum
schießt nicht indirekt dass sie das halt
einfach so auf und deutsche so ein
bisschen beziehen und somit haben wir
quasi diese mod packs und ein bisschen
hier nach deutschland eingebracht
natürlich gab es schon vorher die wahl
apg von technik und so aber wir dann mit
the beast haben das ganze nochmal
das ganze versucht so ein bisschen ja
weißt du nicht so diese diese map packs
ein bisschen hier in deutschland
einzuführen was uns dann auch gelungen
ist allerdings hat mir danach erkennen
ist weil wir uns auch allgemein wenig
damit beschäftigt hatten weil wir
einfach ja wenig zeit hatten da war
hatte sie immer noch seinen seinen dings
nebenbei am laufen seien
das im kindergarten war das glaube ich
ihnen wie sowas und kriege ich hier fall
schaden den krieg nicht mehr
oder dass im kindergarten schade dass im
kindergarten hatte sie mir da noch am
laufen
deswegen musste dann immer so ein
bisschen retten hat wenig zeit noch
nicht so die motivation und dafür
irgendwie so kriegt jetzt keinen fall
die habe ich keinen fall bekommen wir
hin hatten wir nicht so die motivation
noch nicht so die zeitung sammelt
auseinanderzusetzen deswegen das ganze
relativ kontraproduktiv dieses projektes
überhaupt ein mod pack drin hatten wir
uns dann notgedrungen alle möglichen
verdammten infos da irgendwie zusammen
gesucht und so was alles nein das war
ärgerlich das war richtig ärgerlich das
war richtig du von mir scheiße man warum
spannt den bogen nicht länger stelle ich
jetzt nicht da und letztendlich ist aus
dem big daddys projekt von simon und mir
wars anhalt letztendlich das mega
projekt entstanden was wir mit vielen
anderen youtube an gemacht haben und wo
unter anderem dann komme dabei war
zornig den us supreme und noch paar
andere leute alle wo wir das gleiche
immer per quasi darauf hatten oder
ultimate version und mit ganz ganz
vielen leuten das war so ein bisschen
revolutionär für deutschland es gibt
schon so was es gab schon so was in
amerikas gibt alle schon mal irgendwie
in einer anderen variante bleibt doch
stehen besser da war schon shirts
taschen
und was willst du hier schreibst du
solche 34 jetzt ist er tot
ach du bist tot online schade bin ich
wie gut bin ich eigentlich bin voll
schlecht irgendwie oder ich sehe mich
gar nicht in dieser liste
ich habe zehn kinder ja gut hörst du
auch so ich hab's enkel sehr gut dann
ist der andere vielleicht eher eine
kleine zahl davon macht konstant wo ich
hab so eingetroffen und mein gott dann
war heftig schade ich hatte sogar noch
ein foul verdammt
daraus ist dann das mega projekt
entstanden als vorbei ich wurde vierter
für mich geht das was es dann das mega
projekt entstanden was wirklich auch
sehr sehr viel spaß gemacht hat und aus
dem megaprojekt an da hatten wir dann
halt alle jemand die motivation nicht
mehr
keiner hatte regeln beachtet keiner ist
an ihm ins gefängnis gegangen dann was
halt auch so dass alle erhält man konnte
sich alles quasi entschieden man konnte
wenn man ärzte findet super speed v das
motto spaß wenn man ärzte findet konnte
man die verdoppeln verdreifachen und so
was alles mögliche machen letztendlich
man hat ein jetpack markant rumfliegen
mann hatte rüstung mit dem man den lava
schwimmen konnten quasi unbesiegbar war
noch fallen bis zum geht nicht mehr und
das war halt einfach alles nur meinem
wissen dorf und ja dann ist daraus
entstanden was wir zurzeit alle mega
feiern was ihr als community ja auch
feiert regt euch da nicht auf wenn denn
wer denn man witherspoon stadt roth wir
haben ja nicht das war ja nicht mal
regelverstoß es war ja nicht in stadt
roth wir haben ja keinen nix gesetzt
irgendwie wir haben die blöcke gesetzt
die blöcke sind damit dann auch wieder
weg gemacht weil der weinkonsum ob da
gesetzt und es war eigentlich mein der
stadt zwei außerhalb als käfer nicht in
der stadt war
in der stadt waren war es ja so dass wir
den der usa hat uns ja nicht mal gesehen
hätten sei nicht mehr an diese kann aber
alles legal
es ist ja nur ein streich gewesen
scherzt ein bisschen ihr wisst wir
kommen alle super miteinander klar nur
die community halb das immer halt so
hoch als wenn dann der übelste stress
zwischen uns allen wehren dass man jetzt
alle hassen würde nicht den adel und
sowie alle halt kämpfe und so dass wir
uns alle hassen weil wir jetzt in den
usa gesprochen oder so
das muss alles stimmig ist und jedes
quasi das ganze nur so hoch hat sage ich
mal wie soll denn super speed eigentlich
funktionieren kann man alles abbauen
hier oder wie soll ich mir das nicht
vorstellen
ach man kann sich boxen sie habe ich den
keine schaufel oder sowas wie so hoch
wie sowieso können ja alle so schnell
abbauen was schalters oder bauen wir
auch so langsam hab keine ahnung ich
laufe einfach ein bisschen haushalt an
ihm entstand aus dem megapark und hier
macht uns allen mega viel spaß es ist
mega mega geil hier ist echt ein richtig
geiles projekt ich hätte nie gedacht
dass es so was von viel spaß macht
obwohl ich mich damit auch nicht so viel
aus kenne aber mittlerweile kenne ich
mich damit aus wien ist halt das
meistens wirklich einfach nur
herausfinden dass mit der phoenix wieder
zum beispiel die muss ich mir noch
machen dann ja box mithalten dann zb die
geht das mit dem zauberstäben oder so
das ist halt alles natürlich das mit den
ganzen schwertern mit den ganzen extra
sachen halt wie zum beispiel mit den
verschiedenen rüstungen das macht mega
mega viel spaß das ist richtig richtig
geil muss ich sagen das projekt macht
mir richtig viel spaß nicht lag der
server da kann ich einfach so nicht
sprechen ich sprinte ich die ganze zeit
das geht nicht
ja dann kam halt luca film den real life
kannegieser sterbliche break blogs to
restore hangar absurd kaputt machen
dann kam halt links dazu hier
dass ich auf meinem luca film kanal
reallife videos gemacht habe was auch
eigentlich sehr gut angekommen ist
allerdings hatte ich halt nach der zeit
mir gedacht dass ich da wieder umsteiger
von craft und auf kontrakte dann einfach
jeden sonntag ein video machen wieso
können die mich schlagen
so könnt ihr mich schlagen diese kann
ich dir nicht schlagen doch ich kann
jedoch schlagen
dass ich da dann doch die ballerina die
das machen und das ganze jahr quasi
geprägt durch veränderungen
ich habe mich verändert habe sich
verändert vom kompletten charakter bin
ich anders
aber das macht jeder mensch wie jeder
mensch hat sich hsv ich habe mich
verändert
swiss life freunde und es war wirklich
ein jahr das geprägt war durch
veränderung das muss man echt zu sagen
ich weiß nicht wie ich das ja anders
beschreiben würde ich habe sehr sehr
wenig mit youtube gemacht das ist halt
einfach so diener
wenn man das jetzt zum beispiel mit
denen vergleichbar den us blog dammfeld
gesehen spaß den ich liebe dich da hat
die nada darüber geredet dass er beim
webvideo preis war dass er bei mir ja
kraft ist das thema damit mit drei tdi
und den anderen youtube an das schild
und das ist ja auch alles natürlich und
so was alles nur ich bin nicht so der
typ der so was somit den leuten da so
macht also ich habe hier meine freunde
die ich zu seit langem kenne mit den
leuten kommen gut klar und zwar was
alles man verpiss dich geben auf ihn
anders alter pc freaks darunter das
raster fallen tisch mit messer ja weiß
nicht also ich hab halt nicht so viel
mit anderen youtuber nichts gemacht weil
meine zeit doch einfach nicht zugelassen
hat also ich halte jetzt auf mein abi
hierzu und ich werde ja auch später nach
köln ziehen aber aus nicht weil da jetzt
irgend wie alle anderen auf wohn und
weil ich das irgendwie auch schön hin
ziehen will
weil die anderen da alle sind sondern
ich habe mit den relativ wenig zu tun
nur so auf youtube und video ebene
gezogen
aber halt einfach so weil ich da eine
schöne uni gefunden habe ich springe ich
einfach runter nur noch es waren viele
leute am leben
naja vierter bevor wir auch schaffen uni
gefunden hat eine wohnung weil ich damit
zwei freunden in der wg ziehen
und ja dann werde ich entweder nach köln
ziehen oder nach düsseldorf
wahrscheinlich sogar mehr düsseldorf
wurde auch hamburg also können steht da
echt jetzt kann ich gesagt habe ich sie
nach köln also feststehen tut noch gar
nichts ich habe eine unis in allen drei
städten gefunden köln/düsseldorf in
hamburg es sind wahrscheinlich aus dem
auf düsseldorf hinauslaufen
aber ich werde euch da auf jeden fall
auflaufen halten es dauert ja noch ein
halbes jahr jetzt und ja sonst war mein
ja eigentlich wirklich würde ich mal
sagen ich will hier keine einzelnen
informationen zusammen rücke ich kann
doch jetzt nicht sagen dass ich bei dem
event mit dem unterwegs zum bleibt
kann ich nicht sagen weil es einfach
nicht wahr ich könnte sagen dass ich zu
anfang des jahres skifahren war dass ich
an der nordsee war im urlaub mit paar
freunden dass ich immer mal
zwischendurch halt einfach so weg war
einfach dann gamescom video das mega
heftig war der video day wo wirklich wir
alle überrascht waren dass da echt so
viele leute waren das waren ende das wir
echt mega kracher nur ich glaub ich geh
jetzt einfach mal ich könnte jetzt oder
was kommt jetzt
ich könnte jetzt und mache jetzt in der
mail lobby einfach dieses parcours dings
punkt habe ich kein bisschen auf die
melodie hat in letzter zeit ein bisschen
dass ein bisschen schade ja dann
zwischen einer video der über mega
heftig wie viele leute halt tatsächlich
da war das war richtig krass und stecker
disabled player disabled und ja dann im
sommer war ich halt auch wieder einer
nordsee war auch sehr schön sommer war
ich auch in italien auf groups auf
stufen fahrt in jesolo das ist so ein
party urlaubsort wo stehe ich überhaupt
gerade mit der schule und so dann war
ich auch im sommer noch immer weiß und
lebensform er im herbst 2013 wo muss ich
über planspiele hat ich bin das noch nie
gesprungen
im herbst 2013 war habe ich glaube ich
gar nichts gemacht das war was für einer
mine den herbstferien
neben den herbstferien habe ich echt
nahezu nichts gemacht nicht aus ferien
war ich die meiste zeit wirklich hier zu
hause weil wo geht's lang danach keine
ahnung weil ich die meiste zeit zu hause
war ich echt einfach mal pause brauchte
den herbstferien und ja dann in den
winterferien jetzt war ich halt auch
bisher die ganze zeit zu hause vom
zweiten bis vierten werde ich halt alle
in hamburg sein also wenn ihr dieses
videoguard seht hier ist der dritte
wahrscheinlich so gegen 18 30 oder so
also hätte es online kommen müssen wenn
ich habe es verkackt
ich hab doch nicht gestoppt psa
springt linie nicht am kreuz was denn
was mal was mache ich denn hier ich halt
doch gar nicht an
bin ich jetzt in hamburg und halt immer
so unterwegs aber nie aus irgendwelchen
youtube technischen gründen
und ja sonst würde ich sagen freunde das
war's eigentlich das eine blöde jahres
zusammen passen wollten uns ein bisschen
halt mich bei euch bedanken für die
ganze unterstützung die mir hier
gewährleistet wird seit eineinhalb oder
zwei jahren jetzt mittlerweile ist es
krass wie sich alles verändert hat wir
sind mittlerweile über 300.000 leute ich
hoffe dass das alles so weitergeht und
freunde fürs nächste jahr wünsche ich
mir dann einfach das ist halt so
weitergeht und auch dass ich halt
zufrieden werde mit meinem mit meinem
weiteren leben mit meinem studiengang
mit dem was ich danach noch alles machen
werde und so was alles und sonst freunde
möchte ich mich bedanken zwar relativ
spontan das video war ich jetzt gedacht
habe okay am dritten ist nur ein video
am start am vierten auch aber da kann
ich wenigstens noch am dritten noch ein
zweites video raushauen
dementsprechend freunde ich hoffe ihr
seid gut reingekommen ins neue jahr
seit so weiter wie bisher wahrt bewertet
das video jetzt soll es euch gefallen
hatte dass ich einfach so gequatscht
habe und sonst freunde würde ich echt
sagen danke nochmal für das jahr 2013
ich hab grad voll die bedenken dass
dieses video mega viel fett abbekommen
wird weil einfach ich die ganze zeit nur
vom thema abgelenkt war und gespielt
habe nebenbei aber ich hab einfach so
gequatscht und ich finde sowas ist
besser als gar kein video
da habt ihr wenigstens ein bisschen was
und dann würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
wieder wenn ihr wieder in der oper hier
ist anders die neue warte wusste mein
hund die lupe
der guckt mich nicht an der peter weiss
mobil und ja sonst also ich hab halt
wirklich echt einfach mal so drauflos
gequatscht aber das ist besser als nix
und an alle die jetzt noch ein video
haben wollten ihr habt jetzt wenn ich
dann gibt norman rund und klickt das
video weg und die abonniert mich an
alles mögliche ist ihr eure entscheidung
ist euch überlassen der karibik und es
steht einfach da oben auf dem holz
stumpf na gut freunde mich würd sagen
macht's gut wunderschönes
wir sind dann mal wieder und ja